for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out moof
university comm thank you and enjoy
okay so previously we talked about how
we removed the ammonium ion or the amino
group from amino acid number one to give
alpha-keto acid number one via
transamination what happened
specifically to that NH 4 plus it was
added to alpha ketoglutarate to give
glutamate okay so what who cares why
does this matter well this happens with
a bunch of amino acid number ones right
and we're taking that that NH 4 plus and
adding at alpha keto good right to give
glutamate continually and so what
happens is that the NH four plus
oops the NH four plus collects on
glutamates collects on glutamate and so
we got a bunch of it if this keeps
happening if we're continually trying to
get amino acids ready to be oxidized
we're gonna get a bunch of that NH 4
plus on glutamate and basically that
we're collecting a bunch of NH 4 plus
and NH 4 plus I didn't want write it in
white that's right in blue it must be
excreted because it is toxic okay now
that is unless we're talking about using
it to make nitrogen containing compounds
which is not what we're doing here we're
not talking about that okay we're
talking about it building up on
glutamate okay so what happens we've got
to get end up getting rid of this NH 4
plus so what's gonna happen is that the
glutamate dam that is in the cytosol of
a cell will go into the mitochondrial
matrix of the liver and so we've got
this glutamate here and what we're gonna
do is we're gonna have an oxidative
deamination so we're gonna oxidize
glutamate and remove its amino group
okay so we're gonna add water here and
we're gonna remove NH 4 plus and we're
gonna turn glutamates into alpha
ketoglutarate okay now this oxidative
process requires specific
we a an oxidizing agent and that is
either going to be NAD+ or nadp+
right if it's NAD+ that becomes NADH if
it's nadp+ becomes NADPH and this is of
course catalyzed by glutamate
dehydrogenase do you hydrogenate scat
dehydrogenase catalyzes redox reactions
and so when this so the products really
have this reaction at least in this
direction because this read this enzyme
can catalyze the the reaction and the
other direction for reductive amination
which I think I mentioned previously in
a much older video the products of this
reaction going in the oxidative
deamination direction right produces we
produce NH 4 plus and alpha
ketoglutarate that NH 4 plus so of
course we're trying to excrete it safely
and so that'll go through the urea cycle
to be excreted safely as urea okay and
the alpha ketoglutarate since we're
talking about this in the context of
amino acid metabolism it can go to the
TCA cycle where it can be oxidized to
give to NADH is one fadh2 and one GTP or
it can be turned into oxaloacetate and
basically that oxaloacetate can make it
out make it from the matrix out into the
cytosol for gluconeogenesis so that can
happen as well for gluconeogenesis which
I'll just write or abbreviate gng okay
now this enzyme glutamate dehydrogenase
is Alice directly regulated it is
activated by ADP ADP and inhibited by
gtp now the reasons for this I don't
think have been sort of completely
figured out quite yet and I put little
asterisks here on these guys to kind of
indicate that this is as far as my
explanation of it it's purely my thought
and not it's not really my thoughts
about why this happens it's just about
what I used to kind of remember the
allosteric regulation so I think about
this happening in the context of amino
acid catabolism breaking down amino
acids for energy so the the reasoning
here is assuming that we're gonna take
that to the alpha cute little age the
TCA cycle and completely oxidize it for
that energy okay now if that's the case
why would this thing be stimulated by
ADP well ADP is typically an indicator
of a low energy State
so if it's an indicator of a low energy
State and it's it's stimulating this
then that that beans we're trying to
make make alpha ketoglutarate to send it
to the TCA cycle so that we can get more
energy out of it right because we're in
a low energy state according to this guy
that's kind of how I think about it
that's at least that's what I use to
kind of remember this this regulator now
it's inhibited by gtp and gtp is an
indicator of high energy which means we
don't need to make alpha ketoglutarate
right don't make rate and so there it's
not gonna go to the TCA cycle and not
gonna give you these nadh SFI days to
Sgt peas and so there's no increase in
energy right now this doesn't entirely
work for the explanation because that
alpha ketoglutarate could go to end up
producing oxaloacetate which can go out
to produce glucose we have a goodnight
Genesis but I don't think about it that
way just I just used what I just said to
kind of remember this right and I
remember this forward reaction has
written to help me remember the
regulator's so it's not all sort of it's
not an entirely correct way to think
about it but it gets the job done in
terms of remembering these regulators
for this enzyme anyway that's pretty
much it for glutamate dehydrogenase now
there's a question down here of what if
the NH 4 plus is freed up in cells from
tissues
other than the liver right because this
is happening in the liver here what if
that happens in cells outside the liver
that's we're gonna talk about in the
next video so I hope that video is
helpful thank you for watching if you
found that video helpful don't forget to
Like comment subscribe and share with
friends thank you and happy studying